i can't believe mtv asked me to host i
don't know if i was their first choice
or the only one brave enough to do it
during covet
either way kiki palmer hosted the 2020
mtv video music awards and
absolutely crushed it you're going to
get all kiki all
eyes were on the 27 year old actress who
came dressed to impress
[Music]
from her white feather fringed gown to
this chic mini dress with a bow
kiki made the mtv vma stage her personal
runway
but the host didn't just toast the
singer also performed her latest single
[Music]
snack
[Music]
and it wouldn't be kiki's show without
channeling her different characters
i love new york city i mean you never
know what you're going to see
or who you're going to meet baby girl
would you
look in this fly you're fine as a half
chill bucket of wine
okay poetic lines bro but no thanks
the host talked to e.t about her costume
changes ahead of the big night
you're definitely going to be seeing my
characters i'm so excited look like i
said we're trying to have fun throughout
the whole show
and you're going to see me i think a lot
during this show um more than sometimes
we usually get to see the holes just
because this is
a different thing all together so i'm
very excited to have fun in those areas
you're going to get all kiki all what
you see of kiki on
ig you're going to be getting that
during the show
kiki is the first woman of color to host
the mtv vmas and kicked it off with an
inspiring monologue
as rough as it's been there have been
incredible moments of inspiration that
have given my generation hope
one night a fun escape but also
just coming together i think that's also
the big theme of the of of the night too
when we think about it
our whole mind has been going to we're
healing each other you know we've been
dealing with a lot it's been a lot going
on so
this is a time when we're coming
together we're letting the music bring
us uh
together she touched on the black lives
matter movement and said it's time to be
the change we want to see
we've seen our generation step up take
to the streets and make sure our voices
will be heard
enough is enough we can never tolerate
police brutality
or any injustice we must continue the
fight to end systemic racism
the vmas looked quite different this
year the introduction was filmed on a
virtual
stage complete with a digitally
generated audience
how is this show going to be pulled off
in the midst of a pandemic what is it
going to look like
it's going to look different than you've
ever seen it before we're getting as
creative as we can
and trying to make sure that we can
incorporate our awesome audience that
you know the mtv vmas usually always has
but within a way that's safe for
everyone so expect a cool surprise there
but then like i said throughout we're
figuring out all different ways that we
can keep the excitement and surprises
going
um and add elements to the show that
people are going to be excited about and
not feel like oh bummed or that the show
is any different
but before things kicked off kiki
started the show with a dedication to
chadwick boseman
who died on friday after a private
battle with cancer
an actor whose talent and passion is a
true inspiration
to all the fans he touched and everyone
he encountered
we dedicate tonight's show to a man
whose spirit touched so many
he is a true hero not just on screen
but in everything he did his impact
lives forever